13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
have you ever tried doing a core workout
and instead of filling your apps you
feel the strain and pain on your lower
back and neck now it can be tough to
stick through the entire workout if
you're constantly in pain and discomfort
to understand why this happens you first
have to remember that the abs and your
lower back are both part of your core
the core wraps around the entire body
now this includes your abs obliques as
well as your lower back we need the
muscles in our core to support and
stabilize our bodies in everything we do
hence lower back pain during any core
exercises can be first a sign that your
core is too weak to do that exercise
hence your lower back may compensate in
some ab exercises and enough taking too
much of the load second your phone is
off
for instance when performing a crunch
instead of engaging your core and
lifting your shoulders off the floor you
end up straining your neck by lifting
your head off the floor first that
muscle tightness and fatigue as your
muscles get tired they stop functioning
properly and your body will
instinctively look for nearby muscle
groups to compensate this might be the
case on the last few reps if this sounds
like you will stop adding these ab
exercises to strengthen your core
without adding the extra tension on your
lower back and neck
dead back this exercise allows movement
of the hips and arms without moving the
spine lie flat on your back with your
arms extended up to the ceiling and your
knees and hips bent to 90 degrees
keeping your ribcage down and back fully
rested on the floor extend your opposite
arm and leg out return to the starting
position and repeat the movement on the
opposite side avoid arching your lower
back keep it fully rested on the floor
throughout plank with one knee bent do
you find yourself in these positions
arched lower back or butt up if you
struggle to keep your body in a straight
line and experience lower back pain when
performing a plank then start off by
doing plank with one knee bent this
plank variation helps to reduce the
pressure on your spine and puts more
tension on the abdominal muscles so it
helps to properly strengthen a core
without getting the lower back sore as
your core gets stronger that Gambel feet
and perform a normal plank raised leg
crunches raise leg crunches are much
more superior and lower back friendly
compared to regular crunches by keeping
your legs in a ninety degree position
this helps to deactivate the hip flexors
and keep the lower back flat against the
floor so there are no flexion or
extension happening in your lumbar spine
if the exercise is done correctly this
way your abs are forced to do all the
work if your neck is coming up first
watch out to avoid neck pain do not
place your hands behind your head
because this will tempt you to pull
forward and lift your neck up do not
jerk your head forward or use momentum
to lift yourself up
place your hands next to your head and
focus on engaging your core to lift
yourself off your head neck and apps
should be in one straight line and
remember as you crunch up engage your
core and aim to lift your shoulders off
the floor do not rush through the
movement use this exercise to develop a
promise
in your upper abs while reducing the
risk of lower back or neck pain
side plank we know that our core also
consists of the oblique muscles
hence we got to strengthen that as well
side plank is extremely effective to
target the obliques and lower back
that's in a forward plank hold position
slowly root it over to one side putting
the weight on your left arm and foot the
elbow should be directly under the
shoulder place your right arm on your
hip avoided sinking your hips down to
the ground because this can cause strain
in the lower back be sure to keep your
ab muscles tight and hips raised
throughout the exercise
hold this position for 15 to 20 seconds
and slowly rotate back to the starting
position and hold the side plank on the
other side if this gets too tough then
place your top leg in front as balanced
and the last workout is Superman
Superman is a great exercise to
strengthen the muscles along your spine
lie on his stomach legs straight out and
arms stretched overhead engage your ab
muscles and raise the opposite arm and
leg off the floor hold for three to five
breaths slowly and lower them down and
repeat on the opposite side continue
alternating for a total of 10 reps avoid
looking forward which will add extra
strain on your neck keep your neck in a
neutral position by looking down
throughout the exercise these are five
exercises which will strengthen your
core without adding the strain on your
lower back and neck be sure to LIKE this
video and share this video to someone
who might find it useful don't forget to
also subscribe to my youtube channel and
check out more workout videos fitness
tips as well as recipes right yeah all
the best